ah yes the disgusting thing about
Thanksgiving is anytime somebody makes
turducken
National Thanksgiving turkey
presentation President Ford pardoning a
turkey at you know it's like the pardon
what does that even mean parting a
turkey like they're not going to cut its
[ __ ] head off
is that what that means what does it
mean to Pardon a turkey
you don't know he doesn't know who the
[ __ ] what does it even know
let it go back go into the wild yeah
that's what you'd think it is
just disgusting dude
turkey eating competitions and [ __ ]
gross any eating competitions are gross
national Thanksgiving turkey
presentation
um uh what is turkey bowling turducken I
know what that is Turkey
bowling
are you [ __ ] me
a sport in which
oh my God turkey bowling is a sport in
which
uh is based on ordinary bowling a frozen
turkey sources a bowling ball and 10
plastic bottles of soft drinks or water
or bowling pins the turkey has boiled
down a smooth surface for example ice or
a soap covered sheet of painters plastic
I mean so specific using a bar of soap
it is commonly associated with
Thanksgiving I mean I mean what dude
turkey bowling is popular in minor
league ice hockey in the United States
and kind of imagine you [ __ ] die
and like a superior species just keeps
chucking your body down an aisle
like they're doing that with your dad
you know what I'm saying
or did do what you're with your cousin
it's just [ __ ] flailing all around
with soapy water just into some [ __ ]
diet right
like that's so [ __ ] up
like just eat the turkey dude
although turkey's dad who [ __ ] cares
and I always said throw me when I'm dead
who gives a [ __ ]
from me when I'm dead use me dude I'll
take the heat when I die just use me
cart my body around and do some crisp
bowling do some turkey bowling with me
stick some feathers in my eyes I don't
give a [ __ ] man
you know people are like oh like my mama
was always like at my funeral I want you
to play that Neil Armstrong's not Neil
Armstrong what the [ __ ] is it was he the
singer or was he the uh the astronaut
who's the Armstrong
Louis Armstrong yeah uh What a Wonderful
World that one she's like I want you to
play that song and I'm like man when I
die play whatever the [ __ ] you want I'm
not there
I'm I'm there but I'm not there you know
what I mean I'm dead
play [ __ ]
together
I play that dude and do the Macarena as
a matter of fact put me on a marionette
[ __ ] and make me do the Macarena
I just my tongue coming out
I'll give a [ __ ] and don't put me in a
suit either
leave me in my clothes
it's so I hate putting on a suit you're
gonna put one on when I'm dead [ __ ] you
just keep my chains on man
bury me in my Wimbledon shits
oh they didn't do anything to us and
don't put makeup on me bro what my
Jeffree Star
just let me be white as [ __ ] mouth all
open just
leave my hands all contorted rigor
mortis sets in let it set when
Rigamortis Ascension set it and forget
it like Ron Paul peel
and what do we do set it and forget when
I'm dead I'm set dude
and don't be all oh move his fingers
right put the [ __ ] formaldehyde in
and keep them nice ah nah the way I make
a coffin you know how they have the
[ __ ] bodies in chalk make the coffin
that way
make the coffin this way
and just Place me in nicely like a
[ __ ] like it's operation or like a
puzzle piece that just fits perfectly
like something from Indiana Jones that
once you just slide in it unlocks a
whole nother room and there's like
beautiful gold chalices in it that's how
I want to be done dude
[Music]
[Music]